hasta ayer eran viviendas hoy Sólo
quedan escombros 11 regiones de Ucrania
sufrieron ataques rusos en las últimas
horas que afectaron infraestructura
civil y de la red eléctrica y de
acueducto
heno de esa solo con centros móviles de
abastecimiento los residentes y
refugiados de otras regiones del país
pudieron acceder a agua potable
estamos asustados estamos muy asustados
porque no queremos volver a ser
bombardeados Esperamos que nuestros
militares nos protejan y desvíen los
misiles que no escuchemos más los
bombardeos que antes oíamos en gersón
los bombardeos masivos se produjeron
Solo un día después de que Alemania por
fin accediera a enviar 14 de sus tanques
leopardos y que Estados Unidos se
comprometiera a ceder 31 de sus tanques
abrams tras la autorización de Alemania
son más los países que se unen al envío
Canadá fue el más reciente
Canadá enviará a cuatro tanques
leopardos en las próximas semanas
esta donación combinada con las
contribuciones y aliados y socios
ayudará significativamente a las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas que luchan
heroicamente para defender la libertad y
la soberanía de su nación
pese a los anuncios de entregas de
tanques el presidente de Ucrania ha sido
enfático en la necesidad de mucho más
armamento para expulsar a Rusia de su
territorio
nuestras ciudades cada tron iraní que
los terroristas usan son argumentos que
demuestran que se necesitan más armas
solo las armas neutralizan a terroristas
por su parte el kremlin condenó los
envíos de armamento y aseguró que
evidencian una participación cada vez
más directa de Estados Unidos y Europa
en el conflicto